hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the issues
that's faced by any hedonistic theory
has to do with the kinds of human
relationships that we often call
friendships and you know we have
different names for different modalities
of this but there's some general idea
that we have friendship of having
relationships that that matter to us
where the individual person or the group
of people who were connected with matter
as those persons and we we want to spend
time in their company we want to do
things with them and there's some sort
of interchange back and forth not only
of enjoyment but even of you know
helping each other out of what we're you
know called services or offices in
ancient times now for an epicurean and
for any hedonist one of the criticisms
that's going to be made against them is
that they don't really take into account
the value of friendship and so that's
what we're asking about what is the
value of friendship for an epicurean
and why would other people be
criticizing the Epicureans on this point
well Epicureans are saying that pleasure
is the good with a capital T capital G
pain is the bath so if if pleasure is
the good then you know for things like
you know this piece of chalk whatever
value it has for me is just the pleasure
that I get from it and that seems
perfectly fine for food and drink and
and other sorts of things as well but
you know we tend not to like that idea
when it comes to people if we say why am
i friends with that person well because
I get some pleasure from them why am I
not friends with that person well
because you know I don't get pleasure
from them they're not giving something
to me it sounds kind of selfish it
sounds kind of like friendships for
Epicureans or for other hedonist are
just a matter of what you can get out of
the other person so if two people can
get something out of each other they can
mutually use each other they have mutual
usefulness then they can be friends but
it doesn't go any further than that and
we see that in the ancient world and I
think in the medieval and the modern
world as well some people have always
said look friendship is in the real
sense and the fullest sense is not just
reducible to what you get out of the
friend you know their usefulness for
something or even the pleasure that you
get from them there has to be some other
type of value so the question is is
Epicurus actually able to take account
of this so we'll answer that first
though I want to read a few passages but
I think are particularly important in
the the principle doctrines there's not
an awful lot of discussion of friendship
he does say though the same conviction
which inspires confidence that nothing
we have to fear is eternal or even a
long duration also enables us to see
that even in our limited conditions of
life
nothing enhances our security so much as
friendships so that sounds more or less
like you know we're using people we're
trying to get something out of them
we're going to talk about about that
sort of case in just a moment
friendship is is something that's being
suggested to us as prudence right and he
also says of all the means which are
procured by wisdom or prudence to ensure
happiness throughout the whole of life
by far the most important is the
acquisition of friends so it makes it
sound like a friend is somebody
who is particularly useful not just at
one moment but but through the whole of
our life and in the Vatican sayings he
says friendship dances around the world
bidding us all to awaken to the
recognition of happiness beautiful
phrase there does he mean it just in the
sense of friendship is probably the best
means that we have to you know make sure
that we have what we need during life so
we can feel happy by enjoying pleasures
not necessarily with this person or that
person who they are you know in
themselves but you know the functions
that they perform well you know in the
Vatican sayings he also tells us a few
other things as well that we're gonna
get to he says every friendship in
itself is to be desired but the initial
cause of friendship is from its
advantages so what we've got here is a
doctrine that says the initial cause of
friendship how friendship comes about in
the first place in you know in the
abstract and also in particular
circumstances is really a matter of
people finding each other useful that is
by you know you know warding off pains
and and and providing each other
pleasures but we go on from there to
make friendship something
Epicurus would say intrinsically
valuable you know every friendship in
itself is to be desired insofar as it's
really a friendship it is something
desirable it is something that we want
to pursue so let's talk about this
initial cause of friendship it lies in
the usefulness the advantage on
friendship what are those advantages
well he says if friends are people that
we find pleasant makes perfect sense
right you like hanging out with somebody
you eventually become friends with them
you don't like hanging out with somebody
don't hang out with them that because
I'd say because you know it's it's not
enjoyable pains is a bad thing
he also says that
we rely on friends to help us out in
times of need that's one of the
functions of friendship you can tell
who's really your friend when they're
put to the test like you know when you
got a move who's actually willing to
come and help you pack stuff up and
hoops the boxes down the fourth flight
of stairs and take you to the other
place knowing that all they're gonna get
is maybe it's some beer and pizza and
thanks in in return when they could be
spending their Saturday or their Sunday
doing something else
well Epicurus is something else that's
very interesting about this he says that
it's not so much that we need the friend
the advantage doesn't lie just in the
fact that they do do stuff for us we
want to be able to rely on them and
insofar as we actually feel like we can
rely on them we may never need to rely
on them it helps us ward off mental
pains fears troubles anxieties in having
friends as a kind of resource that we
could turn to even if we never have to
turn to them they make our lives better
by just being there as a matter of fact
he's got a nice saying here in the
Vatican sayings talking about how we
ought to how we ought to treat our
friends when things have gone wrong he
says that when we're trying to you know
sympathize with our friends what we what
we need to do is they actually just be
understanding we need to give them
nowadays we would say we need to allow
them to listen we need to listen to them
I'd rather write forget me give you the
opportunity to listen no we listen to
them and we're sympathetic with them um
he also says the person who's always
seeking out help they're not actually a
friend nor is the person who never does
seek help there's something involved in
friendship the act of actually going to
somebody else and saying hey can can you
help me out here not too much of it not
too little of it the right amount is
what generates friendship and
that's part of its advantage you know if
we want to spell this up further we
could say that that's part of what it is
for us to be human beings is to be
creatures that relate to each other in
such a way now I'd be curious is also
going to say a friend should become
something pleasurable in its own sake
insofar as there's anything
intrinsically valuable you know valuable
on its own account
it is pleasure or it's the things that
actually provide us with pleasure the
things that are pleasurable and he says
that friendship becomes that way it's
you know we start out by being friends
with people because they give us
pleasure but after a while the very fact
of being in the relationship with them
attains a certain value so he says what
what is that value well part of it
consists in those close to us the thing
that we enjoy when we are of one mind he
says or aiming at that that state so
there's a kind of enjoyable miss in
feeling in thinking in desiring and
choosing the same way with other people
you know when you're in sync with them
like when you're on a team and you're
doing things very well you know things
are actually coming together and you
feel like you're you're actually of one
mind so to speak you know I I passed the
the ball and the other person gets it
and they they do the layup for the
basket or however it's gonna be right
and kick the ball and somebody else
kicks the goal or I steal the ball I was
always a fullback when I played soccer I
steal the ball and set it up field of
the halfback who gets it to the forward
who gets it into the goal right that can
be the being of one mind researchers who
are working together on a common project
and gradually coming to a convergence of
understanding there's something really
enjoyable about that musicians who are
playing together in a band you know when
egos don't get okay and break up the
band right
when you're making music together it's
very delightful he actually calls
friendship and this is very interesting
for somebody who says there is no
immortality for human beings he calls
friendship and immortal good wisdom is
immortal good friendship is an immortal
good there's something that survives
beyond the death in terms of friendship
for Epicurus and you know if you look at
his last will and testament he actually
did provide for his friends and their
children in in as well he also says that
we place a high value on our own
character that's something that's
intrinsically valuable to us or it
should be and then this shows you how
far friendship extends RAM he says we
also place a high value on the character
of our friends now that's not going to
necessarily happen at the initial stage
where your friendship is on the basis of
utility you know can you give me some
pleasure yeah we can think about this in
terms of dating right if you have a you
know if you're concerned with your
character you want to be a good person
and you date somebody and you go out on
a few days and now you're you know
you're enjoying each other's company and
whatever way that you're happening to do
that you're deriving pleasure it maybe
doesn't matter so much at the beginning
how they feel what they're they're you
know hierarchy of values are what what
they're willing to sacrifice what
they're not willing to sacrifice but as
time goes on if you want that
relationship to deepen to become more
intimate if you want to enjoy a greater
pleasure with them then you really do
need to not only be on the same page but
be concerned with each other's character
Epicurus would say without that you
don't really have genuine friendship
some friendships might remain just at
this level deeper friendships the
friendships that are much more valuable
much more pleasurable those are the ones
that are down here that have these
characteristics so from an epicurean
hedonist perspective at least friendship
can although it doesn't
I always have but it can have an
intrinsic value of itself that goes
beyond mere usefulness it still involves
pleasure because these aren't hedonist
theories right so pleasure is in it what
friendship becomes one of the highest
one of the most enjoyable kinds of
pleasure one of the most lasting one of
the deepest one of the Sakura splendide
so that's why it has such a great role
in human happiness